all right no longer seen as competent
and effective a majority of americans
why do you think it's just now that it
took them this long i think that the you
know
they're a pretty young administration
right only a year and they've there are
three more years to go so uh keep that
in mind um the i word incompetent when
that starts creeping up into uh
basically even in the mainstream media
that is a really big red flag but there
was another i word that started to pop
up last week also in mainstream media
and that was impotent
so
if you add those two things that is no
bueno all right so for a white house
tell me about it
you have that
well i'm not gonna go to you next then
um
they have some significant problems and
there are times when you have to figure
out a way to okay well what are we going
to do we got to have something different
we got to have a new policy we have to
have something that changes things and
you just don't see that on the horizon
the idea that the president is going to
go out and talk about his
accomplishments more doesn't seem to me
that that's going to turn around the
polls it's a hard job all right all
right greg
aside from the impotent part what what's
with the 36 percent who would vote for
him he is soft on crime
right whoa those are the criminals yes
okay is that classic numbers
numbers judge
last week
comedian jim gaffigan said he would have
voted he would vote for joe biden's
corpse over trump and i hate to tell him
he already did
this guy is so not in charge any more
than a walmart greeter is in charge of a
walmart
he's just they're shaking people's hands
but it kind of shows you the trade-off
in the payoff right we always said that
like there were people that were uh
suffering from trump derangement like
gaffigan and others who were so
emotionally damaged that they would
happily embrace the mystery box behind
door number three except the mystery box
was joe biden and now
yeah sure you don't have the tweets
anymore you don't have to think about
the guy who who upsets you and your wife
but now you got crime you got inflation
you got the border you got covered
policy that's all over the place you
have ukraine you got china but hey you
don't have this is what we're dealing
with right now because a select group of
elitists could not bear
the tweeting
okay
all right well then harold i'll ask you
this most americans feel that the
country is going downhill that you know
they have all these negative thoughts
and connections it's divisive uh it's
it's downhill it's struggling it's
negative how is how is biden gonna reset
according to chuck todd and make it make
americans look at america differently
you reset you focus on the things they
want you to focus on i've said before
what has he done well he needs to do it
he's not he's obviously not doing enough
one of the one of the numbers in the
poll which i think they need to realize
also in the nbc polls 64 of
african-americans support president but
it's a loan that's a low number for for
democrats i've got to be mindful of that
and inflation task force at daily
provides us with updates on what we're
doing to unclog the supply chain to
ensure that we're able to get i think
the root cause of some of this inflation
to a crime task force you got to get
your fbi a director we got to figure out
in chicago new york los angeles denver
atlanta baltimore memphis where you have
these crime such that you put people you
have not only just to talk in the press
room but how are we keeping track of
these things and how are we dedicating
and allocating resources three the
border without question 60 of americans
oppose what he's doing on the border
that's a recipe for a loss not only in
the midterms but going forward i've said
before three of the four past presidents
were down at this point in
administration and they came back two
others were down they lost carter and
trump you don't want to be that if
you're buying you want to figure out how
you get on the winning side you're on
the winning side by walking with the
people not in front of them not behind
them but alongside them and they're not
doing enough of that right yeah which
means you have to feel their pain and
speaking of feeling their pain now uh
there's a percentage of americans who
think that uh the pandemic is
responsible for inflation uh jesse and
another percentage feels that uh it's
not what do you think biden has to do
how does he play it
well
it's both things that are causing the
inflation but biden hasn't really done
anything besides that one attempt to
lower the price of gasoline that shows
that he's focused on it and then he
flies and looks at ukraine and then you
know he focuses on the voting thing but
he's not zeroed in on the pain that
people are experiencing the big problem
he lame ducked himself in that abc news
interview he said you know what if i'm
not healthy i might not be healthy i
might not run again and the whole
country was like oh my god it's real
and so after that when you combine that
with his performance i think we're
underestimating how damaging the video
of him tripping three times up the steps
of airs force one was still constantly
looking at the notes the light schedule
and then you have a disastrous year when
you anger everybody republicans
independents and democrats that's hard
to do so the media
is struggling on how to cover them you
know some corporate media they can see
the writing on the wall and they're
already looking at 2024 and then you
have people like over at cnn
who are scrambling and like they're
blaming trump and they're blaming fox
and they're attacking mansion they don't
know what to do and that's not for good
for business either so it's like
trump broke the media and they still
haven't figured out a way to put
themselves back together okay i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis